republicans vowing to make dr fauci's
life very difficult as the nation's top
infectious disease expert hangs up his
lab coat fauci will be stepping down as
president biden's chief medical advisor
in december ending nearly a half century
in government dr fauci has been a
lightning rod of criticism over his
handling of the pandemic and push to
lock down the country one op-ed says
fauci should simply just fade away the
new york post editorial board bidding
good riddance to dangerous dr fauci
klein is coveted guidance disastrous
value making the media rounds to defend
himself from the onslaught watch here
with kovid i mean the things that we
thought we knew in the beginning turned
out as the months went by
to not be the case that was interpreted
by many as flip-flopping or not really
knowing what's going on when it really
was the evolution
of the science there is a weird
obsessive violent ongoing demonization
of you by the right that is hinged on
kovid what we're dealing with now
is just a a a distortion of reality
making it look like
trying to save lives is encroaching on
people's freedom
but while he might be done with his job
congress is not done with him
republicans vowing they will hold fouchy
accountable if they win back control in
november
dr fauci retirement or not is going to
be spending a lot of time
in front of a congressional committee
and committees if republicans take back
control he hasn't ever testified in
front of the house since kovid started
so there are so many questions that that
members have we've already told dr fauci
to preserve all of his documents i hope
if republicans take control
that they will get to the bottom of
everything from the origins of covid to
all the manifest failures of the public
health establishment particularly dr
anthony fauci all right tyra so he'll
gonna say goodbye in december what do
you think he ain't going nowhere i mean
he's not even gonna wear a mask on the
mask dancer like this dude's gonna be
everywhere
he's gonna be working on throwing
pitches me doing every possible tv show
he's gonna give dr drew pinsky a run for
his money uh he's gonna do his tours and
stuff the only thing i i just at this
point we need to focus on getting this
country back on track we get if the
republicans get the house start fixing
things that matter chase and fauci
because he's you can't argue with
science it's like arguing with
somebody's religion apparently it
changes all the time so that's going to
be his defense well we didn't know this
but now we know that and we would have
done this you know it'd be like that
country song if i knew now what i didn't
know then yeah so
and it's going to be a lot of stuff and
it's going to get away it's going to be
a huge distraction
he's gone let's
he got he was smart he left because he
knew the firing was coming so you know
he keeps his pension and we're going to
deal with him on tv shows but we need to
get back to business and and shoring up
to where the next time something like
this happens we have people in place
that don't make those kind of mistakes
we did a lot of media a lot and they
accepted almost every invitation here is
just a montage of some of the media
reacting to dr fauci's decision
always pushing for science first in
president trump's white house fauci at
times exasperated his face in hand the
doctor who guided the us through the
coronavirus pandemic and saved countless
lives there has never been anyone else
like him and there never will be again
he was through the face of the messaging
as he was pushing uh strategically and
diplomatically against the president who
often was pushing in the wrong direction
i don't think it's an exaggeration to
say that there there are millions of
human beings alive today who would not
be alive if not for the work that
dr fauci did coordinated and led
wonder if they would say the same about
president trump and operation warp speed
but maybe not why aren't the
journalists treating this guy like a
dangerous quack we have all the evidence
that the lockdowns destroyed small
businesses a generation of children
didn't save lives i mean he was letting
people cross the border in droves on
vacs but he was like no don't fly in
from canada what is this guy doing he
has destroyed this country you don't do
that and then get to ride off into the
sunset
only defense secretaries can do that
right now this guy has come out the day
he announced he was retiring and went on
the most liberal network in the country
and did an interview with the most
liberal host in the country
and praised the president who coveted
elected and says i'm not really sure why
people think i'm political this is
exactly why people think you're
political he needs to comply with every
subpoena they slap him with and if he
doesn't we should shackle him and maybe
we should raid his house and look for
collusion with china because those are
the new rules apparently we're just
playing by them he says that he was just
trying to save lives now how many people
in world history have just tried to save
lives i'm not going to make a dangerous
analogy because i don't want to get
caught doing that but i had a friend
he had a hurt leg and he goes to the
doctor and he says doc my leg really
hurts the doctor says okay we're gonna
do some surgery put some under amputates
his leg the guy wakes up he says i can't
walk anywhere you took my leg off and
the doctor says hey
is just trying to save lives
that's fouchy there are really dumb
doctors that do dumb things and are bad
at their job it doesn't mean you have to
kiss their butt on their farewell tour
yeah he also did neil cabuto earlier
today let's play a little bit of that
i didn't shut down anything there was a
lot of consideration among the white
house
task force and the record will show
neil that we didn't recommend shutting
everything down we wanted to cause a
pause questions were and it's easy to be
a monday morning quarterback here but
that it went too far that particularly
for kids
who couldn't go to school except
remotely that it's forever damaged i
don't think it's forever irreparably
damaged anyone but i think obviously and
you if you go back and people
selectively kneel pull things out about
me
i was also one of the people that said
we've got to do everything we can
to get the children back in school
jessica do you think that he is like
looking at the long arc of history to
get his legacy correct
i i hope so this is a man who's worked
for six presidents and someone who until
a couple years ago um when i think the
demonization of this
health bureaucrat went completely
haywire the stuff that circulates on
social media with him the idea that i
guess republicans think it'll be a good
midterm strategy to run on uh all of the
congressional hearings that they're
going to have on hunter biden and dr
anthony fauci when people are concerned
about kitchen table issues and things
like that you know i welcome it but when
i think about dr fauci and i'm not
saying that things were were not
mishandled and rachel linsky has been
doing the circuit as well talking about
what the cdc got wrong i'll be thinking
about 2014 when he publicly hugged nina
pham the dallas-based uh nurse who
contracted ebola the first person here
he personally treated her that's
something he's famous for throughout his
career or what he did in the 1980s
during the aids epidemic when those
people were demonized treated as
outcasts he lobbied the government
alongside of activists to make sure that
more people with aids could get into
clinical trials and he saved countless
lives there so this
move to always reduce something to the
last minute in time and to forget
decades of service for this man i think
is a huge injustice and again it does
not mean that i think that things were
perfect
but it is a wildly unfair read of this
man's career and i think it is
an awful and painful end to someone who
has given this country
that many decades of service
was a great president until that whole
watergate thing right
go ahead it was the biggest test and i
would argue with you that covid is a
kitchen table issue we're still feeling
the effects of it and by the way he
wasn't just the doctor in america he had
international for all the reasons you
said he had international power and fame
100 million people are now in poverty
because of the lockdowns that he was
behind um people and and again uh look
at how the people that he hurt it's not
just children how many old people died
of loneliness how many people didn't get
to go to their grandma's funeral or hold
her hand or their mother or father um
his big mistake was he didn't follow the
science the science of natural immunity
and if he had recognized natural
immunity which was scientific and
established at the very beginning we
would be in a different place today but
being anthony fauci means never having
to say you're sorry because the media is
fueling this godlike complex that he has
this lack of humility that you just saw
right there the guy thinks he's god um
he's like an authoritarian monster and
he led our country on a
chinese style
approach instead of an american style
where we look at science we consider all
these great scientists that we have in
our country including the ones who
signed the barrington declaration he
tried to shut them down shame them
censor them that's not america and
that's chinese and he has to be very
honest the comparison to china is
ludicrous what are you saying
in your house and they left a piece of
old fish outside of your door because
they wouldn't let you out come on the
chinese keep people in concentration
camps rachel he was an apologist for the
chinese and was very non-transparent
with the lab and the origins and we all
need to look at and by the way the last
thing i want to say is the reason we
need these hearings that it's smart for
the republicans politically but more
importantly it's important for the
country we don't want to repeat this and
we need to put him um on in these
hearings to get to the bottom of that
and then the cdc coming out with its
final report soon as you mentioned
rachelle wolinski is doing that so we'll
be able to nitpick that as well coming
up california governor gavin newsom
cracking down on a radical drug policy
in his state but is this moderate move
part of his plan for higher office hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now